1908 a German housewife came up with a
solution to get rid of bitter tasting
sediment in her coffee she punched nail
holes in a pot and covered them with
blotting paper then she placed ground
coffee on the paper and filled the pot
with hot water it worked so well that
she started selling her coffee filters
worldwide these coffee filters are made
of 100% cellulose fiber harvested from
slow growing pine and spruce trees in
the forests of southern scandinavia the
raw material produces paper but let's
about three ounces of water pass through
it in approximately 40 seconds that's
the optimal saturation rate for
producing good coffee thirty percent of
the paper cellulose content is left over
from earlier production the other 70
percent is raw cellulose fibre the
materials go into a machine called a
popper which works like a giant food
processor it blends of raw materials
with hot water making a fiber soup
called Paul
a paper making machine spreads a
one-inch layer of Pulp across a wire
mesh belt water jets cut a straight edge
on both sides as moisture drains down
through the belt the pulp forms a soggy
sheet of paper it has a water content of
80% all this happens at an astounding
pace the machine lays down 1,300 feet of
Pulp a minute at the next station heavy
compression rollers squeeze almost half
the water out of the paper a tool
applies a crepe texture this increases
the surface area of the paper and
improves filtration speed
[Music]
next they use 38 steam-heated rollers to
dry the paper completely the roller
surface temperatures are around 250
degrees as the finished paper exits the
machine a camera registers the location
of holes dirt or other defects that have
to be cut out
it takes the machine 45 minutes to
produce an 11 mile long sheet of coffee
filter paper the roll is transferred to
a cutting machine the paper is sliced
into two foot rolls so it can fit in the
filter making machine sensors in the
filter making machine make sure the
paper is aligned correctly at the
machine's first station tiny needles
pierce holes in the paper to enhance the
quality of filtration
[Music]
at the next station a stamp imprints the
company logo in the paper a knife slices
the paper in half creating two
side-by-side production lines from this
point forward each line enters a folding
station where guides fold the flat sheet
in half a roller emboss is a seam
connecting the two layers of paper along
the bottom inside then a second roller
cuts the conical shape of the filter the
machine produces 4,000 filters per
minute the next station cuts the filters
apart and collects the leftover paper
which will be recycled into fall the
filters are sent to an automatic
counting machine that divides them into
stacks of 80 the machine feeds the
stacks to the packaging line an
automated packaging machine aligns each
stack with a flattened box then it opens
the box with a vacuum and inserts the
filters see if the machine sensor
detects a problem like filters in the
wrong position or missing filters it
ejects that box from the line this
factory produces a few different types
of filters how the cellulose is
processed into pauper determines how the
filter will perform for example the
factory processes sale is finally to
make filters designed to brew strong
coffee fine celos produces paper that
drains slowly keeping the water and
coffee beans together longer resulting
in a stronger flavour